okay good afternoon um i don't believe
we have any um
bomb scares planned
because obviously they're planned um
uh and i'm surprised uh the number of
people who want to turn up to find out a
bit about programming history i take
this as a positive sign
okay
either that or you need a gentle snooze
at the end of the day having filled your
head with all kinds of technical wonders
um i'm going to take you back to the
past
concurrent affairs um procedural
programming unlocked see every now and
then i do a talk where
some element of the title is
deliberately provocative nobody nobody
else i mean maybe i should take a
picture of you and just post it came to
it would come to a talk on procedural
programming because that's just like a
thing that you don't do that's a bad
word
i kind of want to reclaim that because
people normally use some particular word
and they overload it with either the
word meaning of good or the meaning of
bat and they will and at various points
in the history of programming the words
good and bad have meant different things
um you know you go to some functional
shops these days and they go oh that's
so object-oriented as if it's a bad
thing um whereas yeah you get a lot of
people looking at the object-oriented
code and they kind of go your object
oriented code is really procedural and
it's a bad thing um these paradigms all
kind of jostle up against one another um
they're all kind of good they all have
their context of applicability they all
influence that this us at different
points they also dominate our thinking
and that's the failure
excessively getting absorbed by one
approach
um and and i've always been you know
yeah kind of hot and cold about
procedural programming then i realized
when i look back at my career the number
of times that an idea had actually come
from the procedural space it's just oh
that's interesting
i didn't really appreciate that but more
importantly how many of the lost
contributions
were from the procedural space and
they're kind of coming back which is
kind of interesting
so let's talk a little bit about that um
my name's kevin henney um i have an
interest in all kinds of stuff um from
kind of architecture level to
um coding level detail um
and
so
i'm not gonna really be talking about
anything related to these books it's
just kind of context um i'm interested
in how all this stuff fits together and
i'm very interested in paradigms
and functional programming was a real
eye-opener to me uh when i encountered
it
um
a very long time ago um
over 30 years ago let's just let's just
let's just kind of not discuss the
numbers okay greater than 30 years ago
because at that point i had been
programming in fortran and c and trust
me c is the greatest relief in your life
when you have worked with fortran it is
just it's the feeling of not hitting
your head against a wall anymore
it's just wonderful particularly doing
systems programming
and i started reading up on all these
other languages and these different
styles i came across functional
programming
i was then also fortunate to end up
doing
a um
a master's degree where i looked into
parallel computer systems
and uh kind of
focus and actually implemented a virtual
machine that was kind of a lisp well
it's kind of an object-oriented
functional thing
and and it's kind of nice to see this
kind of coming in a bit more to the
mainstream now there are a lot of people
these days who are saying you know
functional programming is making a
comeback no it's not it's done it's come
back if you look at the lines they've
plateaued
it's
it's it's kind of done its bit and
everybody really these days has kind of
gone for
hybrid
or pragmatic
i love this because when people use the
word pragmatic it's a short way of
saying not
you probably encountered this you know
we're doing pragmatic tdd
we're not doing tdd we're doing
pragmatic agile we are so not agile
we are doing pragmatic functional
programming we call that procedural
programming
when you actually look at a number of
the concepts and you add in you go to
functional programming you go what if
the functions aren't pure
what if just functions call other
functions
huh
what if we just
share stuff that's good next door i want
some of what they have
so there's this whole thing of like
actually that's what functional
programming degenerates into um
you're not careful and one of the things
that characterizes functional
programming or rather procedural
programming from functional programming
is a different model or a discipline of
state
um and you can arrive at some of the
same solutions by different parts a lot
of people mistake immutability for
functional programming
immutability covers a much larger space
functional programming is the
answer that you get if you say what if
my functions have no side effects
if you start the other way you end up
with a very similar solution what if i'm
not allowed to change data well that
means the only operations i can have
can't have side effects um they they
have a kind of equifinality you get to
the same destination by two different
routes but that point about state change
is kind of important
because when we start throwing in
concurrency and i'll come to what do i
mean by concurrency because guess what
there isn't a unique definition if
you've ever been in a talk and somebody
said this is the definition of
concurrency
they are not entirely correct it turns
out this is not a standardized term you
can quite have to pick up one book that
says concurrency is things running
simultaneously on different you know
actually they are genuinely in terms of
physics running simultaneously and
you'll pick up another thing saying that
is not actually the case they are time
sliced with respect to one another you
can go even further and say
not even there mate co-routines stuff
like that which i will be talking about
so it turns out that at different times
with different people they have a very
strong opinion about the work and
currency i'm just going to define
my terms here i'm using concurrency like
we do in english
okay it means things happening at the
same time any other qualification i will
make clear
so when we throw concurrency in and it
can degenerate in various ways
and fragment if you like um
there is a question of state change
and one of the most obvious mechanisms
that people have in the past employed
and they said oh yeah i'm gonna throw
threads at the problem
okay
and
they got themselves into terrible
trouble
which honestly if you're a consultant is
great um
because people have kind of gone at it
with the idea of saying well i went on a
course i've learned about a library it's
a very common problem that we have is we
often think ah it's just a library i've
now got this capability i'm just calling
it it's just like
it's not just a library
when you introduce concurrency into a
non-concurrent environment
what you do is you change the laws of
physics of your program
you change the nature of time there is
nothing more profound than that
by the way if you're ever dealing with a
bug related to concurrency you can
console yourself with that feeling i am
exploring the nature of time and deep
questions of philosophy okay that
probably sounds better than i'm
debugging some damn threading book
but there is a point here it's not it's
not a minor thing i keep finding people
say oh yeah i just kind of sprinkled
some threads on the code it's just it
doesn't work like that i changed the
laws of physics about how our system
runs and it's not working anymore
well yeah when you look at it it's kind
of obvious you've changed the nature of
time now why does this happen
so we're at the end of the day it's time
for a quadrant diagram let us talk about
this quadrant diagram quadrant diagrams
are nice and easy that's why i put it at
the end of the day
there's normally one quadrant that's
very very good or one quadrant that's
very very bad we basically divide the
universe into four so here are the axes
i have some state
and over a particular interval of
interest
a particular period of time of interest
this state
may or may not be shared
in other words it is shareable it is
shared or unchecked
okay
also over this period of time it may or
may not change
it is mutable or immutable and notice
i'm saying may change i'm not saying it
has to change the possibility that it
could change you know there are things
called if statements you know you don't
have to commit to that path
so in other words we have this quadrant
diagram and it turns out
that it's actually surprisingly easy to
write
systems that are concurrent
as long as you have a clear sense of
which is the bad quadrant
now i'm red green color blight
but i have chosen shades that i know
work
and red is nature's color of danger it
is the color of blood
in other cultures it is the color of
celebration again i refer you to the
consultant's remark
top right hand corner you don't want to
go here this is where the pain lies
that we can even call it we can give it
a name synchronization quadrant now what
is interesting here
is it turns out three quarters of the
diagram
is is a safe space
it's a it kind of almost falls out it's
just like well
if you don't share your data you can do
what you want with it you can change it
or not change it you know i can't see
that it doesn't matter to me
this is kind of like the classic unix
process model
you know the unix process well whatever
you're doing the privilege of your own
process you know that's your own
business i'm cool with that but i can't
see that state
it doesn't matter to me even though i
may be running concurrently with you i i
can't affect that it's not shared with
me i can't see it in other words
that's totally safe so that's a really
simple way and that is the kind of
classic unix way unix historically had a
really negative opinion about things
like threads
it's just like no we do everything with
processes because they are a natural
unit of isolation a natural unit of
fault tolerance
and a natural unit of safety from the
point of view of the program
okay let's take a different slice
what if i can't change the stuff
this is by the way one of those
interesting observations that we need to
talk about when we talk about words like
synchronize what is it that we are
synchronizing
we are synchronizing change what if
there is no change again more philosophy
what if there is no change then you
don't have to synchronize ah well that
that problem went away really quickly
so that's the other axis okay so what we
have is these are the safe spaces
top right hand corner
yeah things are going to happen at the
same time we can all see it and maybe
we'll change it maybe we won't are you
feeling lucky
so
this bit which bleaches out terribly in
the light but let me let me clarify a
few what this says functional comfort
zone this is the functional comfort zone
functional programming is based on
functional purity with the consequence
that naturally things don't change
immutability is part of the landscape as
it is with many declarative approaches
this is great you get this for free with
the paradigm
top left hand corner is the procedural
comfort zone
you can change your state
but you don't share it with anybody now
this by the way is also historically why
we ended up with the problems of
everybody in the in the right hand
quadrant why do we end up in the
discomfort zone
because we were all over on the
left-hand side
because it turns out that the lower part
used too much memory and was too slow
historically
and everybody was probably in the top
left top left-hand corner they had this
idea
imperative programming you are entitled
to change state whereas actually you
need to approach the modification of
state is a privilege not an
entitlement and when you look at it like
that if everybody's doing that and
somebody suddenly says okay
we can now have threads and things like
that
it's just like right we all
wander over into the new territory using
our thinking habits and programming
languages and we bolt things onto our
programming languages
even the new ones java is a really good
example a language that was created
after we actually ended up with kind of
a fairly decent operating system
threading being introduced
invented a new and it was kind of like
let's develop an object-oriented
language from scratch and then just bolt
on threads
it's just like they feel bolted on
that's because they are that's not that
doesn't make sense in the way that the
language is designed
and it's why it's painful
so there's a kind of an interesting
point here we've ended up here for
reasons of history people go in there
they say right i'm entitled to state
change how do i do this in a concurrent
environment wrong
you are basically gotta approach it like
what if i don't change the state
okay
or what if we don't share
what if we keep everything separate
so
this is the kind of interesting list a
couple of other points of history um
dykstra introduced the word mutex but he
didn't introduce the construct he
introduced a thing called the semaphore
um the difference between a mutex and a
semaphore these days a semaphore is just
a lock
and anybody can lock it and unlock it
basically and let's be very very clear
about the purpose
of
any form of lock
the purpose of a lock
is to eliminate currency
so whenever anybody whenever you say so
why are you guys you know kind of
using all this threading in your code we
want better performance why are you
using all these locks because we want to
kill that performance
but they never say that
it's funny you know the whole point is a
lock is the anti-threat
okay that is something when you all
computers wait at the same speed
okay
this is the point about moore's law when
it comes to waiting
you know you can have a three gigahertz
multi-core weight or a one gigahertz
single call weight you know what they
actually have the same amount of time
so
he was introducing semaphores but he
referred to one
as
a mute he just gave it the name mutex
for mutual exclusion and that name was
then later picked up to give a much more
specific meaning of a lock with affinity
in other words it knows who locked it
so somebody else can't come and unlock
it okay that that's that's the
distinction um and he talked about
critical sections we aim to make
critical sections governed by mutex
rather short in other words this very
simple piece of advice just for context
this is dijkstra writing in 1968.
there is a small chance we might have
learned a couple of things since then
but there are days when i wonder
um now david budenhoff who is involved
heavily with posix threads which kind of
really can't standardize the stuff in
the 1990s this was all up for grabs
posix threads are very much native to
linux in the way that that's expressed
the api there
the only other unix that was really
seriously doing threads in a way that
people noticed was um
sun's operating system they had a
slightly different model
and naming i worked on i worked on a
system that used posix threads for
real-time systems before that it was
actually standardized it's very awkward
trying to write things to a moving
standard um and that has not changed but
one of the one of the great comments
from david butenhoff was i've often
joked that instead of picking up
dijkstra's q acronym
of mutex we should have called the basic
synchronization object the bottleneck
because that would change everybody's
conversation
yeah you know what oh what should we put
here i think we should put a bottleneck
here
it's one of those things where you say
it out loud it's just like
yeah
i read something about immutable state
yeah let's go let's you know let's go
let's go along and do that and leave
those locks alone
and for just an understanding of why it
is that we really need to understand why
people have
done an extraordinary job of really
screwing up the performance of large
classes of systems
um this is uh from the it here
and it's basically a logarithmic
projection and and sergey uses the same
metric that i've used for years the
width of a laptop actually helps us
using a smaller laptop my laptop's about
30 centimeters across that is that is
one light nanosecond
give you kind of a sensor calibration
and i've always used that just to remind
people that speed of light is shockingly
slow i mean it's fast from a human
perspective but
one light nanosecond that's a cycle time
of one gigahertz suddenly that doesn't
sound so fast and that's only over a
space like this you start stretching
that piece of string and everything
really slows down
but what is impressive when you start
looking at all the optimizations
available to us and you hit threading
thread context switch direct costs
that's really slow compared to that
indirect costs
the slowest thing on the graph
threading is a magnificent way even
without locks slowing things down so we
must be really careful about anything
that does that you have to really have a
particular problem that looks like a
particular shape the amount of
performance benefit you can get by just
saying you know what we're going to put
this in a single thread and really make
this work it's impressive you know it's
i've had that with teams it's just like
have you thought about doing it single
threaded no no no no no we've got all
these threads kevlar yeah i know and
it's kind of like they're all treading
on each other's toes it's like trying to
get everybody simultaneously through
those doors at the back it's just like
yeah you've got a stampede problem here
so
there's this wonderful talk it's almost
coming up to 10 years i can't believe it
brett victor's the future programming he
gives this talk as if from the
perspective of 1973. it is wildly
entertaining and deeply depressing
okay and he's basically looking at the
landscape as it was in 1973 as the
possible futures
and he wasn't talking flying cars here
although i still harbor a deep amount of
disappointment about our lack of mars
bases and flying cars
um
but
this is great he looks into the future
they said threads and locks they're kind
of a dead idea right or dead end right
i think if we're still using threads and
locks we should just like pack up and go
home because we clearly failed as an
engineering field it's just like one of
the most perfect mic drop moments and
there's a deep truth to it so let's open
up the variety we normally people
presented with locks and threads and so
on there's a whole bunch of other stuff
i mean there's stuff that goes off the
top of the screen off the bottom of the
screen there are a lot of different ways
of expressing ourselves so that this
thing kind of does something either
absolutely simultaneously with this or
kind of simultaneously or kind of
asynchronously we need to be a little
bit careful because certain words
in people's minds have got
attached to a particular meaning
so we see a lot of languages these days
with the word async popping up
the problem is they all mean something
different
whereas if i see the word if in a
particular programming language and then
in another there's a pretty good chance
i know what i'm looking at if i see
while
yeah four little bit of variation on the
syntax but actually it's still the same
idea async can mean almost anything
ultimately all concurrent programming is
asynchronous
but because you've changed the
synchronous nature of time it kind of
stands to reason
but different
apis and languages come down on this is
our async
so don't get too attached to a
particular meaning and if you see it in
one language be very careful about your
interpretations of it in another piece
of code sometimes it might be similar
but it might be a false friend um now
what i'm going to what i want to cover
here is channels co routines parallel
blocks and pipelines these all came from
the procedural world
okay
um and uh they all
let me think
what do we got
1970s 1950s
1960s
and we compare it to this these are not
the only these are great primitives
these are great
tools for making stuff out of but they
don't you don't want them messing
messing around with your high level
application
but there is another area of threads
that people tend to talk about these
days i've noticed coming back green
threads um that's kind of been
popularized by
uh certain work consent spaces a green
thread
is a kind of a post-hoc name it's named
for the java a green team at sun who
implemented an approach to threading in
java in the 90s and there's renewed
interest in this but green threads are a
much much older idea um i was using
green tents before they were called
green threads so it gives us a strange
way of talking about them but they
technically they are user space threads
as opposed to kernel threads they are
threads that run within the application
on the thread of the application rather
than in the operating system
which means that they can be relatively
cheap but there are some interesting
issues that come about
with that but they're not true operating
system threads
and they will be um as it were
sliced up on that threat
and there are some subtle bugs that you
can get when they don't behave like what
many people now consider to be true
threats in other words something
actually runs uh or rather something
that's an operating system threads and
then there's true threads which run uh
one per call okay there's these varying
degrees and people like to put the word
true or real or concurrent or not
yeah the landscape is interesting but
this is how we kind of slice it up or
fragment it
so green threads have kind of come back
in because people have realized you know
those context switching costs us can be
they can dwarf um
the the overall benefits and that's
quite important because why is it that
people want to do the stuff
and sometimes it is a direct say it's
directly saying i want to have the kind
of concurrency that allows me to exploit
the concurrency in the hardware or the
parallelism of the hardware i want that
kind of that's why i am doing this but
actually for many problems and one of
the original reasons that people got
interested in this stuff and why event
driven programming all this kind of
stuff is interesting it's that idea of
saying
i would like to organize my code around
the shape of the flow i want to decouple
things
that in other words it's an act of
decoupling now if you've ever had the
experience of looking at certain
event code or async code or threaded
code you're sitting there going like no
this is a tightly coupled
a pile of goo it is anything but
decoupled guess what welcome to
programming there are things you can use
for good and for bad it turns out that
the same construct that you can use for
decoupling things can also be used to
couple things tightly together but the
idea is your the original goal was let's
decouple these two things which are
relatively independent let's decouple
them in time whereas we might think of
normal
discussions of decoupling as being
spatial decoupling the kind of stuff you
draw on a diagram
space in that case is only a metaphor
but there is that idea that what you're
doing is decoupling things in time i've
got these three things and they're
relatively independent but i don't want
to have to make a choice and really i
shouldn't be having to make a choice
about when and what they happen and i
don't want to write the infrastructure
that does that that's why people want to
do that so
there are these these two things are not
you know they're not contradictory they
sometimes overlap but the desire for
performance i want to make the most of
the concurrency available to me
and i want to decouple the expression of
my solution
those two are actually they pull you in
slightly different directions
and which is why green threads become
interesting now green threads are
related to a thing called fiber a fiber
is kind of a construct
relate it's a cooperative multitasking
everything i've kind of implied but i
haven't said explicitly so when we use
the word thread we normally mean that
something is preemptive
in other words it's not down to the
subject matter or the task at hand as to
when things get executed
um we can switch at any point and that
may mean that that is actually running
on a you know you have one single core
and the operating system or the runtime
library
is sitting there going like i think i'll
interrupt now and switch to another
thread
or actually we've got two separate cores
two pieces of hardware that are running
this simultaneously
and i was preemptive we're not saying
that there is it's not bound to the
nature of the task
and that also applies to green threads
but
fibers tend to not work like that fibers
tend to be
often they are and the distinction
because they are often confused with
co-routines um
and nobody's ever formally defined them
but i'm going to use the sinkable human
knowledge wikipedia to help me the
distinction if there is any is that co
routines are a language level construct
a form of control flow this is kind of
important come back to that one in a
moment while fiber is a system level
construct that doesn't mean their
operating system but the idea is that
i can see
co-routines in my code i i i may have
keywords and things like that you know i
will say here is this
whereas a fiber is something i may
launch
but then
something else will get executed on
completion or at a particular point an
io point for example in other words
things run to a particular point and
then there's a handoff there's no
preemption there's no there's nothing
slicing time up in the background
um but the idea that co-routine is under
the programmers direct control
and is therefore a control flow
construct is really important because
most control flow constructs everybody's
quite happy with the idea of you know
i've got ifs i've got wilds and then
i've got various flavors of these things
that's what people get tall but
co-routines are a control flow construct
now this is interesting because
they kind of become popular again
so let's um you know co routines are
computer pro so just on a point on the
word
there's very relatively few languages
these days that use the word subroutine
so if you're a vb programmer you're
familiar with this um
but you know the only people who use the
term subroutine are vb programmers
fortran programmers and star trek script
writers
um
if you listen carefully you will always
notice they referring to subroutines so
apparently in about the 23rd century all
this comes back into fashion okay
the point there is pause for a moment
because we often don't think about where
our words come from pause and go
sub subordinate co
ah right
it's a it's a symmetric version it's
this idea um jet they are a
generalization in other words
co-routines
are not a kind of a new subordinate idea
because sabo is already taken
co-routines are the root idea and
subordin and the sub-routines are kind
of like a special case of them when you
think about it like that
um non-preemptive multitasking by
allowing execution to be suspended and
resumed in other words under the
programmers control it's not at magic
points it's not under magic preemption
or anything like that
and
historically
you can
donald knuth in the first edition of the
art of computer programming volume 1
written in the early 60s
where he talks about he shows you how to
implement co routines subroutines are
special cases of more general
programming components called charities
in contrast the unsymmetric relationship
or asymmetric between a main routine and
subroutine there is a complete symmetry
between co-routines which call on each
other now canoes
was not the inventor of co routines now
that that claim
goes to
a particular gentleman called melvin
conway
anybody come across conway's law
okay yes same conway conway's law was
1968 and it's it's an observation about
or the relationship between an
organizational um an organization and
the things that it designs you know it
establishes a kind of homeomorphism
between it's just like yeah the shape of
your team or the communication party
team will influence your architecture
and people are often surprised wow
comey's really old
not as old as his previous one of his
major contributions 1958 okay he
invented the co-routine this is a paper
of his
talking about her construction of a a
cobalt compiler
in the early 60s and he makes the
observation co-routines are subroutines
all at the same level each acting as if
it were the master programming when in
fact there is no master program it's
kind of like a mystery story and it's
just that the co-routine notion can
greatly simplify the conception of a
program when its modules do not
communicate with each other
synchronously how much code has been
spent in the intervening decades where
people end up going oh i wonder how to
do this anybody got a switch statement
and a flag handy or let's write a state
machine all this kind of
no need it's already you can do this
it's an idea that's been around for a
very long time
we find it and we found it as kind of
standard feature in some languages bliss
was a
systems programming language in the
early 70s
came out of bell labs but you might be
more familiar with another systems
programming language that came out of
bell labs
that's the great thing about
laboratories they kind of invent all
kinds of things and then one of them
either wins or the other one loses so
bliss ultimately lost out to c
um but there are some really elegant
design ideas in bliss and bliss had the
co-routine concept and importantly it
didn't make a distinction between it was
a very primitive
kind of co-routine concept
it's a systems language so therefore you
expect it to be relatively level the
body of any function any function you
don't have to have special keywording
here
may be activated as a co-routine and or
asynchronous process
so let me think where are we half a
century on from that this sounds pretty
cool i want my languages to do this now
it is assistance programming language so
let's look at this let's look at the
syntax
and i will tell you when i have not
implemented this
i will tell you code that i have swiped
i have not found a bliss simulator so
this is stuff i've just taken straight
from the papers
um
you have a process name process
identifier pit
your function call but now you put the
word create in front of it now it's a
sister's programming language and you
know yeah space is scarce so you
actually have to go and say
by the way i'd like you to execute this
co-routine over here so if you've got
memory allocation to be done
you need to have done it that's not part
of the co-routine construct that you
don't get that for free um it kind of
gives you it basically says you give me
the space and i'll do the rest of the
work oh and by the way please make sure
you tell me how big that is because i
really want to avoid buffer overruns huh
interesting that c did not do that
um and then really cool idea you have a
continuation when you are done with this
you can now execute a separate
instruction or operation including
another function call
it's just like hmm this feels really
kind of fresh there's some really good
ideas here i'm happy to forgo the please
work out where you want the stack and
tell me how big it is i'm happy to give
that one up the rest of this sounds
pretty good and you have a very simple
exchange a very simple model if you
wanted to switch context you did it in a
very as i said you can build more
sophisticated mechanisms out this is a
systems primitive
this is the value on resume you get when
you say i want to swap between this code
with the co routine i currently am and
another one but when you return to this
point of control you get a value back
and you can to say i want to resume that
one please tell it this is the value to
pass so it's equivalent extraj
honestly please if you are a language
designer please have these conversations
out in the room so that people use the
keywords and you avoid things like xj
because it doesn't work i'm sure it
looks great and logical on paper but
when you use the words people hear them
they go yeah you know that's a really
bad keyword just just a suggestion
um
so we've got that it's a really
interesting idea you can build much more
sophisticated systems out of this but
this is appropriate for a systems
language um
and so why would we want these things i
mean they are one trick pony you know
we're just using them for a bit of you
know asynchronous web server writing
it's just like well no the web didn't
exist back when people were inventing
this stuff co-routines are well suited
for implementing familiar program
components such as cooperative tasks
exceptions event loops iterators
infinite lists and pipes holy crap
that's like that's a lot there's a lot
here
and that point about iterators is really
interesting
um so this is a paper from 1974
uh
by barbara liskoff and her team you may
have come across the list of
substitution principle which was named
in 1991 by jim caplin based on a 1987
talk by barbara liskoff yes it's the
same barbara liskoff who won the
cheering award in 2008 for her work on
programming language design as well as
distributed systems and this is one of
the key contributions this language
research language
um
foreshadowed all kinds of stuff you know
it's not something anybody used in
production but there's loads of stuff
here basically abstract data types all
of that kind of language
and iterators i mean the list does go on
there's a whole load of exception
handling stuff as well but the iterators
um
and let's go off
and team noted iterators are a form of
co-routine
huh yes however they use sufficiently
constrained that they are implemented
using just the program stack
for anybody who's used c sharp
this is exactly the same thing in fact c
sharp pretty much lifted this idea and
this idea of implementation um uh front
clue because i remember looking at the
thing in c sharp with the yield keyword
and i said i think they're gonna like
that looks a lot like the clue one yeah
you know
because i'm a programming language nerd
and i happen to have read this paper
years ago it was like this looks really
familiar and it also looks like some of
the other things here in the ruby space
and all this
but what was interesting
was when i saw it in c sharp i thought
oh oh i wonder if they've done it i
wonder they've done it i wonder if
they've gone and given back co-routines
to the developers no they hadn't they
said oh you know this is a special case
we can get rid of the actual coaches oh
they're so close you could almost taste
it
but you know we can we can live with
that so here's a bit of clue let me
translate this for you
string channels is the name of the
iterator type uh ita tells us hey guess
what this is an iterator it takes an
initial argument it yields i love the
keywords here it yields a character
um
we've got you know we're going to start
off with an index it's a one counting
language
modules are indicated
um
uh
using dollars rather than dot notation
um
let's see if that one works there we go
there we go dollar sign there we go so
that's instead of dot which to the
modern eye is kind of like oh that's
kind of intrusive
so
but it's it's all there and then we have
this really nice little bit where we
have the actual bit where we yield and
we return to the caller and then we
re-enter this and it keeps our state
none of these crazy state machines or
big switch statements or anything like
that and no need for threads for a lot
of problems you have this idea of here
are two things in cooperation you know
i'm gonna i'm gonna give you a value
when you want more you just let me know
okay and i'll just go around the loop
and all the state is managed for you
elegant simple
and very 19 very early 70s okay so the
1970s was not just about
disco and you know great rock music
it was also about iterators and some
good language design now um here is how
you use it you know all those people
it's just like oh hey this is really
cool what's really cool about this
what's really cool is
that's a modern for loop
how long did it take languages to get
beyond the old for loop it's a for loop
you're just counting yeah but maybe i've
got ways that i count you know like over
collections and things like that no
no we're only going to allow you to take
a number it's just like yeah so this is
a this idea is caught on it's kind of
nice
now if i translate this to python
i can kind of do very much the same
thing and we see the same kind of
keyword there it's you know it's pretty
much identical there's the yield keyword
and we see this popping up in a number
of languages but that idea has been
around for as i say a remarkably long
time and again there's that for loop
and this is kind of 1990s
so
in other languages we see this idea
dominated very heavily and was actually
part of the reason for their creation
um design and evolution of c plus plus
by beyonce stroudstrap he
published the book in 1995 which is
actually now
seen it's actually
it is further from now and
you know it's it's almost we're getting
to the point where
the time between now and that no
actually it is and his first c plus
compiler um you know it's actually this
is written closer to the first c plus
plus compiler than to the present day um
but at that point he described
the motivation he said the first real
code to be written in c with classes
before i had the name pl c plus was the
task library
that's why he actually wrote the
language to implement
a simulation library based on
co-routines but decided not to put co
routines in the language decided to have
them as a library construct
and somewhere in history that library
construct got lost it's it's you know
it's lost somewhere in the 1980s if
somebody can kind of find it you know
between the indiana jones movies um and
uh hair metal you know please return it
to the present day because it's it was a
really interesting idea um and it was
all based around a simple library task.h
but that one got neglected now there's a
point here about what actually happened
why have we ended up with the historical
narrative that we uh that we've got
because preemption started becoming
normal for operating systems everybody
used to have simple single threaded
operating systems with cooperative
multitasking models doesn't matter if
you're a mac or windows or you know if
you were dos then actually you really
just did have nothing else you know dos
these days now means denial of service
and you know that's been true for
decades
but there is this idea that the only
people that actually had access to true
preemption were on 32-bit workstations
and that was not most people so
therefore this this was the standby but
this idea co-routines were just going
out as i came in
it's just i'll see you as they went
walked out the building
all these kind of residual design ideas
and bits and pieces of libraries that
are no longer supported
that language similar
in its first form these days we know
about similar 67
as being the kind of the the the
progenitor of all object orientation
it's an extension of algol but before it
got classes its most important idea was
hmm let's have co routines that was the
idea it's like if you want to create a
simulation language how can you have how
can you model a real world or do
anything with how can you do anything
event based that was their thinking in
the 1960s how can you do anything event
based and make keep the code simple
unless you have the idea of co-routines
um
and so that was the simple idea um
similar one 1965 no objects but it had
co-routines to enable this idea which
were governed by an operating rule which
was basically the life cycle of the
thing
and they were co-routines it's not just
a kind of curvature they work our
routines they look different to a lot of
modern co-routines but that whole idea
of objects have a life cycle the
original vision of object orientation we
might say i was like yeah you've got
encapsulation you got in polymorphism
you've got inheritance and you've got
concurrency but people found it really
difficult to count to four so we kind of
dropped one of those but it was integral
to the object paradigm
and a lot of the stuff also kicked in
when we started talking about structured
programs so co-routines are a
surprisingly old idea they are coming
back
and they are about control flow which is
interesting because a lot of the
languages that people are noting that
adopting co-routines they're going like
yeah you know what this is all very um
this is all very uh
new to us
and what is surprising for them is not
only how old this stuff is but there's a
bunch of other ideas here about how this
stuff is
structured and people were talking about
control flow that is a way of organizing
your procedural programs so there's an
interesting thing sometimes oh yeah i'm
using this language in that language and
it's really functional no
most of what's been added to programming
languages in the last half decade has
been borrowed from
you know procedural hand-me-downs with
its control flow functional programming
is not interested in control flow there
is no flow there is no time
yeah it feels like a statement from the
matrix there are also no spoons in any
of these languages
but there is this observation it's all
built around procedures
and the the object paradigm grew out of
procedures
a procedure that can give rise to your
procedures your functions they've got
state
they've got variables and you can nest
functions inside them
what if you could hand off that state
and it lived longer and it didn't just
end when you hit the closing curly
bracket
a thing which has behavior and state in
it wow that's a really interesting idea
somebody should do something about that
and they did
so in other words object orientation
came from this
so let's have a look at a
co-routine implementation of sleep sort
this is in python we are using the async
keyword
and what we're going to do is we're
going to launch a bunch of things we're
not actually going to launch any threads
but what we're going to do is we'll just
make things available with respect to
time
and all the scheduling is done within
python there are there is no threading
here
um
and
so
how does sleep sort work and this is one
of those
this is one of those um algorithms you
you never get taught at the university
it was only event in 2011
um by somebody on 4chan
it may be the only good thing to ever
come out of 4chan
um
you see how it works it lets everything
delay for a particular amount of time
wait for it wait for it there you go
nine seconds
um you know
very elegantly simply implemented no
excessive
use of resources but please please do
not go into work tomorrow and say we're
doing sleepsaw this is how we should
present user data
but there is a point here it's a very
simple implementation there's no race
conditions or anything like that it's
just time-based and very simple
expression of time
how else can we kind of explore co
routines well let's talk about fibonacci
numbers
um because i mean somebody needs to
choose one of these silly examples but
actually it's quite a good example
um of course there's the whole thing
with fibonacci that you know there's a
whole load of jokes about it
i'm gonna i'll go to this use fibonacci
convention it'll be as big as the last
two put together
um
i think it's funny
but maybe i'm just influenced by this
joke what did you think of my fibonacci
joke it was as bad as your previous two
fibonacci jokes combined um you know but
we got that there so i can write this so
let's i'm going to write this in c plus
plus given that we just talked about c
plus plus that's right this is c plus
and so i've got a standard recursive one
now
the point about this is that it yes it
works but it's hideously inefficient
because you go and recalculate all the
numbers but it is elegant and simple and
all the rest of it so maybe we could
cache our state rather than recalculate
it maybe we can cache our state and in c
plus plus i can create objects that look
like functions so maybe i can do it like
this and i'm expecting you to kind of
hold on to this but the idea is now i've
introduced state i'm going to hold on to
my previous values so when you ask me
again it's just like i've got this one
and when i say it is the sum of the
previous one and the one before that
i've already got these in stock i'd have
to recalculate them brilliant fantastic
or
as or c plus plus 20. we can use co
routines are they like bjarna's
co-routines
no they're not
but here we have it generator returns
into fibonacci and then we get a magic
yield keyword but obviously because it's
c plus plus you can't have
you can't have everything simple so we
put co in front of it and so yeah this
is looking really good it says there's a
logical flow here it's just like yield
the first two values and then go around
the loop and you don't need to have any
remembered other object state because
it's just your local variables that's
your state
and nobody else can see them you just
reveal it as you go
and you can print out this stuff and you
can use it in a for loop
and you end up with the first 20
fibonacci numbers that was fantastic
this is brilliant if i write it in
python
it looks pretty much the same okay you
know modulo some idiom
yeah that's kind of nice
however there is a dark secret here
if you look very carefully you go so
kevin you can tell us what generator
angle brackets int is
yeah
yeah you see c plus didn't quite finish
the job
people might say that as a general
statement i couldn't possibly comment
um
so
this is how c plus plus approaches
parentheses i believe that my swedish is
correct i have checked it modulo the
ikea uh
uh extras
um yeah it's like c plus plus said yeah
we've got co routines and we think
they're really powerful but we're not
going to give you everything you want
something you've got to build it
yourself
absolutely got to build it yourself
you've got to here's generator
it's a lot of skeleton code and then
there's this other thing which you have
to then define which is but you've got
to do it yourself
every single time i've ever tried to do
this i've had to spend
a lot of caffeine
and a lot of blog posts to try and get
the right nuance
and it's a case of like yeah it would be
nice that they finished it it's kind of
like it's one of those kind of like yeah
we could be bothering but here you want
to carry routines you got them it's just
like what's
this you know
really having seen what co-routines are
in other languages not quite what i had
in mind
okay let's go back to structured
programming structure programming was
originally about sequential programming
but also in the late 60s and early 70s
there was exploration but we didn't have
the hardware at the time but there's no
shortage of ideas
maybe it was the drugs who knows there
was there were plenty of ideas around
that okay
and it's kind of like
there was this kind of exploration of
all these ideas so there was a
structured concurrency
um
and dijkstra talked about it in that
1968 paper i just referred to
he said when a sequence of statements is
surrounded by the special statement
pairing par begin and par end this is to
be interpreted as parallel execution of
the constituent statements
just as you know certain languages use
begin end or open curly closed curly the
idea is well let's have a special
version and instead of executing it from
top to bottom we execute it from left to
right so to speak so these are all done
you know at the same time for some
definition of at the same time they are
done concurrently this idea was in there
it's been around for a long time and in
fact uh it made it into algol 68 and the
clue to the language is in the number um
however that said to be fair and honest
uh uh you know uh the final report was
1973 because guess what it was kind of
delivered late um but yeah here's the
1968 language but it's kind of half a
decade late i hope nobody minds
this however is one of the most
influential languages you've either
never heard of or never used
um if you've all if you wonder where any
of these you've seen these keywords in
various languages
this is where they came from nobody was
using these words in any of the other
languages at the time um they had a
position for abbreviation and uh and
certain things so they a lot of ideas
this was hugely influential language um
so the initial report had this influence
but it also had this idea so i can write
this begin if any vdvc that will execute
top to bottom an alternative notation
because keyboards didn't have curly
brackets was to use parentheses that is
a standard block okay
executes from top to bottom
unless i put the word power in front of
her
in which case they all execute
concurrently for some definition of
concurrent
and that's just like oh well that's
that's kind of logical now
where i really first encountered this
was
in a language called occum which is kind
of as dead as a doornail at this point
but 30 years ago it was it was quite a
what actually 1980s but there's some
really interesting ideas in it and it
basically tried to generalize
the whole concept and say well look
you've got two ways of executing a bunch
a bunch that's very technical here i
have a bunch of statements how would you
like them executed would you like them
from top to bottom or all at once
and so you would choose in other words
you didn't have extra qualifiers you
basically said i want this one in
sequence it executes top to bottom i
want these in parallel it executes all
at once it's really and everything
aligns because they're the same number
of letters oh my goodness it's like i
designed this
and they even generalized the for loop
what is a for loop if not a sequence
repeat it
so
from i equals one four three
in sequence is this
and you can do it in parallel as well
so you could generalize you had a
parallel fall it's just like it was all
that really nice design very very
elegant
but there's a point here that was
parallel blocks which people have been
trying to kind of reinvent but rarely
try to put back in the language they
often do it via a library but it's such
an elegant way of thinking it kind of
recognizes the
the top to bottom nature versus you know
i have a set of things would you like
them in sequence or simultaneous that's
a really nice idea
but let's explore another quadrant here
looking at the procedural comfort zone
unshared mutable data needs no
synchronization there was an idea
kicking around the late 80s early 90s
called the coordination model uh david
galento and colleagues uh came up with
this the linda model of uh concurrency
and distribution
and it was this idea that perhaps if you
separated and this is a very powerful
design idea that you can apply anywhere
um you don't need to
it's not bound to their thinking but the
idea we can build a complete programming
model out of two separate pieces
computation okay and coordination in
other words computation here computation
bit is rather than taking nicolas
birth's
algorithms plus data structures equals
programs which is a very it's a book on
classic structure programming we take a
different view programs our coordination
plus computation and we make we make it
so that what we're doing is we have lots
of little pieces of computation and then
we glue them together and we have maybe
the glue is blue language is the same
maybe it's via library or maybe we use a
separate language but we treat them as
architecturally separate and there's a
beautiful clarity to this
you can test your computation easily and
take a step back and now how would you
like to plug it together that's a very
and that's a as i say it's a powerful
way of thinking
um
but as they say computation model allows
programs to build a single computational
activity a single threaded step at a
time computation they were really clear
about this keep it simple because people
can do that right
now
configure your coordination is and how
would you like the result of this to go
to this one
now although i say that this is their
specific language and description of
this
was late 80s early 90s
actually we've seen the idea before
and actually very explicitly the kind of
the idea of the pipeline
and
pipelines are really nice because they
allow you they pipelines are friendly
because they allow you to reason about
things
they allow you to reason because the
bits in the in a simple pipeline the
components the parts you're putting
together that sequence as a human being
i can read from top to bottom on a good
day
and that's like okay i can do that i can
understand what's going on
you may notice that one of the things we
miss in most of our programs
and our programming languages is the
ability to express concurrently on the
concurrency on the page it's normally
launch this or send something off there
it when when you look at the code
squinted it and look at the indentation
there's nothing that says parallel there
okay
there's nothing that tells you that it
looks like that we have relatively few
notations that afford that um kind of
classical music
stave notation is is a good example of
actually here is a notation that is
truly concurrent um but we don't really
have that so what we do is we simplify
this we say look two ways i can think
simply the flow of the data and the flow
of the control and we you know that's
the elegance of a pipeline the pipelines
are really old this is doug mcelroy's
1964 paper where he designed this
it took uh it took ken thompson six
years to find the pipe
symbol on the keyboard
but that was how it was implemented that
this was the original unix pipe before
there was even such an idea of unix
and this idea is incredibly elegant we
should have some ways of coupling
programs like garden hoses screw in
another segment when it becomes
necessary to massage data in another way
this is the way of i o also this is kind
of the unix way but it's a very it
doesn't solve every problem
but historically
pipes were the coordination language for
procedural programs that's how that was
one of the ways that they were supposed
to be bolted together we keep the bits
procedural in a way that seems to be
relatively efficient and widely
understood at the time and then we
combine things differently
and
so
we kind of have that kind of view but if
we kind of jump a little bit
there's an observation here
and this is about another observation of
mcelroy's so we jump into this quote
mcroy's review is both an explanation of
an exemplar of the unique's way this
kind of ties in with dan
dantos north's talk yesterday the cupid
uh when he's talking about cupid
properties he talks about the unix way
and it's a very important way of
thinking even though none of the
universities seem to follow that anymore
it's an it's a profound way of thinking
it's compositional small programs do
elementary tasks but which are written
so they can be combined in complex ways
and this is also important because it
gives us this idea of composability
again something that people find easy to
reason about and composability
is a property that we have with
pipelines but not with locks and threats
if you try and take a piece of code that
works with locks and threads and you
combine it with another piece of code
that works with lots of threads you've
got absolutely no guarantee that it's
going to work at all it may deadlock it
may just do the wrong thing because
they're not they both have strong
opinions you've got two pieces of code
that have strong opinions about the
nature of time it's very difficult to
mix those
so
there is a kind of an observation there
when we talk about these things a lot of
these things are based on cueing ideas a
pipe is just a cue with a bit of
discipline okay
and it's a it's a point to point you
know producer um consumer q although i
always like to think if you want to
really pep up your vocabulary and
confuse your colleagues don't call a qrq
call it space time decoupling because
that is exactly what it is
it is either you are decoupling things
spatially within the code or in time
we'll come back to that later that's all
you can look at any queue and it's a
space time decoupling
um no actually please don't take that as
a naming recommendation because
otherwise i'm going to get a lot of
flack for that kevin i thought you said
all this kind of extra word naming was a
bad idea yeah but honestly space-time
decoupling sounds cool use it in a
meeting just not in the code
now typically we do this because it
gives us natural asynchronicity we end
up with a construct that is buffered
it's bounded and it's buffered watch out
for anything that is infinite and
unbounded it looks kind of good in
computer science paper but it's a
terrible terrible idea because it means
you are subject to
bad producers and bad consumers when you
run out of memory you suddenly discover
the finiteness of infinity in practice
okay
it's a painful experience so yeah always
go in with a strong opinion
in the limit you can have a buffer of
one and it's still considered
asynchronous it's kind of a mailbox
metaphor i'll just put this here you
come back for it later i'll leave it on
your neighbor's doorstep you can come
back for it later type thing
interestingly enough if you make that
single place so that even on that level
it's useful if you make that single
place a single use
we have a name for that it's called the
future and the other side of it's called
a promise
it turns out we don't need most of the
things that people add to programming
languages is just like
squinted them right and it's just yep we
have this we already have this it's a
primitive from another point of view
but what about
what about a queue
that has no capacity whatsoever does
that even make sense
and it depends it's a question
perspective no it's not asynchronous so
if you ask if you're your definition of
of cueing is
yeah it's got to be asynchronous then
it's then it isn't
but then again this is a little bit like
the number zero for a long for most of
human history the idea of actually
having a number for zero was a
ridiculous idea
um but actually having a having this
actually makes sense it implements a
construct known as a rendezvous where
both of you you can go off and do
independent things
but you both have to be there at the
same time for that we actually have
another name for this this is called a
channel if you're treating it's a
primitive construct rendezvous are an
idea that we used in a few languages in
the 1980s um and still i think is one of
the more elegant ways of doing this
but a channel is a fundamental construct
the idea of like we've both got to be
here at the same time
i've got no space to buffer things so
you better be there i'm going to wait
for you
okay you can see there's a limit to this
but
you know this was a fundamental idea
that tony hall introduced
in csp communicating sequential
processes um i mentioned the arkham
language earlier that also had this kind
of stuff it was this idea in fact this
is wonderful so my copy of jones and
goldsmith they have this wonderful
example like yes you can implement
anything with parallel constructs the
idea sometimes you know a little bit of
fun that sometimes you have you take a
simple problem and you make it
ridiculously hard
it's just like fizz bars or anything
like that actually this it's not a new
idea i i love this book because it's
just like okay there's that's what an
assignment looks like in arkham i
shouldn't freak you out too much that's
what an assignment looks like
or
oh this semantically equivalent
to let's execute a let's execute two
processes in parallel across a shared
channel and i'm going to send you this
value and you're going to receive it in
a variable you need never write a simple
humble assignment statement again
okay
this is semantically equivalent i'll be
very careful about the word semantically
equivalent because it really isn't when
you start looking at the generated code
and the expressions on the your
colleagues faces
um so but that was all built this arkham
language was built out of csp
um and as he said we shall observe the
convention that channels are used for
communication in only one direction and
between only two processes
now the channel idea
i was introduced to in occur these days
people are more likely to use go that's
the language that was influenced by them
they also get the option by default
channels are indeed channels i described
them they are zero place they are
unbuffered they are synchronous
uh they are rendezvous mechanisms but
you can customize them to be much more
like cues and you can build all these
other constructs so the terminology
shifts a little bit here but it's there
so
we can and there's a beautiful
switch where we can take something like
a function and turn it into something
like a running process that might even
be considered an object i'm gonna take
i'm gonna have two channels
they're both gonna be channels of string
you know one's gonna send we're gonna
use one to send strings and the other to
receive strings i'm giving the name push
and pop
and i'm gonna run a function called
stack and that function is gonna have a
simultaneous concurrent existence with
where i have called it from and my only
means of communicating with it
actually go allows you other ways but if
you are using if you're not going round
the back and kind of like actually i'm
going to meddle with things
if you just use the kind of like the
easy off-the-shelf stuff you can use
channels that's the only way we can talk
so there's no locks but we do have
synchronization because we have channels
so the idea is you don't get to say
right we've set all this up here's the
data by the way please remember to
please remember to lock in and lock out
but then leave the door open that's kind
of like most you know kind of lock based
programming it's like please don't touch
the thing you're supposed there's a
token over here please please pay
attention to it
most people just walk in and try and
grab the thing
hence race conditions here it's a case
of like we're not even going to let you
do that you have a discipline you go in
that door and you come out this door
simple as that you want data well you
want to you want to push something onto
the stack send down push channel you
want to see something listen on the pop
channel
so if we push ndc nice arrow notation
nice one there push london
and then we print the pop of it we get
this in reverse order again notice the
nice little arrows they thought about
this one
we have a kind of question what happens
if i do that and what happens if i pop
an empty stack
yeah good question i'm gonna i'm gonna
be a very much a computer scientist
about this one and say well we're gonna
leave this one as unspecified
that's a very elegant way of saying we
did not solve the problem you're on your
own kit
actually what it means in practice is
as tony hawe highlighted something very
fundamental here
that is a weakness of this approach but
yeah this form of failure is known as a
deadlock okay but i'm going to say that
that's a feature it's not a bug if you
do the wrong thing that is on you um
there's a simple state model you know a
stack it can be
empty it can be non-empty and if you
push it when it's empty you get what you
want if you pop it when it's not empty
you get what you want if you push and
pop when it's not empty you get what you
want
if you pop it when it's empty you get
what you deserve
okay
but what's the code look like
so this is the nice things what we do is
we kind of folding around
just for clarification sometimes go is
very much a procedural language it's a
procedural language with some data
abstraction ideas and some channel ideas
but most of its features it's very you
can you can find go through history not
surprising based on the authors those
ideas were already around but it is very
much first and foremost if you look at
its dna this is modern procedural
programming
in fact you can do other things in it
that's great but that's its default
access in other words if i just sit
there and write stuff that's what it's
going to look like and these ideas all
came from languages that were procedural
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
say i've got a function it's got local
state i want my local state to persist
we have this conversation earlier wrong
with objects what if i could keep the
state around for a while well here i'm
actually going to do it i'm going to
make a function continually exist and
then talk to the function and it's going
to have its local data forget all that
private keyword stuff this is so private
you can't even look inside it you know
this really is very private it's inside
the block and i've got a forever loop
and the first thing is basically
i'm going to take the depth if the depth
is zero we are empty so i am prepared at
this point you know i'm going to listen
i'm going to listen out for
at this point i'm going to listen to a
push i'm not listening for pops if you
do that you're stuck okay but i'm
listening for push and i'm quite happy
to do that i'm going to modify my own
internal state accordingly
if i'm not empty then i must be
non-empty
so one of two things can happen
either somebody pushes something onto me
or somebody wants a value they want to
pop so i can receive so there's
something happening on one of two
channels a listen or a send okay so
that's how i decide a different control
construct okay basically a
non-deterministic control construct
again another 1970s idea
but it's basically a case of in this
case
i'm listening on push if i receive a
push then that means i receive a new
value and therefore i will append it to
my array of values and therefore i've
now received that value and i'm a stack
that now has one more value than it had
before
on the other hand if i if i'm hearing a
pop then i'm going to take that uh that
last element off and then slice it down
no it's not the most efficient
implementation that's not my intention
here but what we've got here is a very
simple idea i've just taken
a simple construct a procedural
construct and turn it into a co-partner
and go routines as they're called and go
they are not exactly co-routines they're
not exactly threads that's kind of all
scrolled away at the back but there is
this idea of you think about it in terms
of channels you don't think there's a
thread over there that i want to talk to
and i'm going to lock things and unlock
things you say
we fired that off and we're going to
have a conversation we just better make
sure we have the right conversation okay
this is a kind of question of
orchestration in the code
okay so the final trick
wouldn't it be fun if you could actually
get rid of that array
because that array
yeah it's okay
but we already have a stack it's called
a runtime stack why don't we use the
runtime stack to express the stack
there's almost an xkcd cartoon in here
so let's do that
when you create a stack it's initially
empty that's your forever loop
and when you call a function called
non-empty stack
then
you go into the non-empty stack you call
it with the value that you're keeping on
top top is now a local variable
so now when somebody says i would like
to pop this you return your local
variable you return the value the one
value you had on the stack and your
returner
or you call yourself again with the new
value so now you know if you're not
comfortable with the cursion i'm sorry
this code is really not going to help
you it's not going to make you more
comfortable
but what is interesting is that this
approach to express so we've just
replaced the stack with a stack genius
so yeah this is the summary of the talk
um
no more of the point
this is actually idiomatic if you were
doing this in erlang again another
language whose influence and his model
the actor model definitely not a
procedural thing that hence why it's
outside the scope but i want to show you
there is a convergence here we can
actually see how this touches on to some
of these other ideas but or more
importantly how it relates to other
paradigms and there's an adjacency
between paradigms which people don't uh
which don't appreciate sometimes and
sometimes it's hard to see
but from a historical perspective
i want to go back through all of this
stuff and it's just like it's not that
i'm it's not that i'm hankering for the
you know 1960s or 1970s honestly you
know some of the music is great but we
get to listen to that music these days
that is what you know that's that is
what things like spotify iv it allows me
to access the past without having to put
up with the food quality of the past and
other issues like that
uh on the other hand
there were fewer pandemics back then so
you know it's a bit of yeah the point
here is that what we need to do is say
hey look that feature is really nice
it's coming around again that's in that
language and i have seen this before
it's a better sense of history so i hope
that that's either screwed with your
mind or educated your history or given
you something to think about or is going
to make you dive into a glass of wine
right now because i realize i am the i
am the obstacle between you
and the evenings entertainment so thank
you very much for your time